42 years ago when the world of computing
was just taking shape physicist Richard
feineman took the stage at MIT to give a
keynote speech he started by admitting
that he didn't know what a keynote
speech was but then went on to talk
about something that he thought nobody
else at the conference would talk about
what he shared was his vision for
Quantum
Computing Quantum Computing is a
technology that is coming into its own
right now and the breakthroughs that
we're seeing today were in many ways
anticipated by fineman's brilliant
insights in his 1981 lecture but then
you can't claim to know anything about
it this video is a collaboration with Q
control a global Quantum technology
company headquartered in Sydney that
makes this technology useful through its
infrastructure software products for
Quantum Computing and Quantum sensing
many of the animations that I'll use in
this video are from Q control's
educational platform called Black
opal Fineman dared to speak about
quantum computers the same year that IBM
released their first personal computers
it was a time when computers were big
bulky machines primarily used by
businesses for recordkeeping with tiny
amounts of storage and RAM the internet
didn't exist and yet Fineman already
wanted to push computers to their limit
he titled his talk simulating physics
with computers something that meant he
had to First admit that even physicists
don't understand the world perfectly I'm
not absolutely sure of anything and
there many things I don't know anything
about I don't feel frightened by not
knowing things even today there's a lot
of physics that we still don't
understand and so we need computers to
help us learn more but what kind of
physics do we want to learn about some
Physics can be approximated just fine by
solving things like differential
equations finean G gave this speech
after people had traveled to the Moon
after all using math and physics that
could for a large part be computed by
hand when Fineman says simulating
physics with computers he is referring
to the task of trying to mimic or copy
physics to create an accurate simulator
of our world he isn't talking about
other tasks like adding numbers or
sending emails those you can do just
fine on a normal computer we already do
a lot of simulation on computers to
approximate nature fineman's Vision was
to move away from approximations and
invent a computer that could do exactly
the same as nature Fineman says that the
physical world is quantum mechanical and
therefore the proper problem is the
simulation of quantum physics quantum
physics refers to the world of the very
small since a Quantum is the smallest
possible unit of something on the
quantum scale particles can seem to
behave stange L existing in a cloud of
probabilities only collapsing into a
definite State once we measure them
conventional bits in a computer ones and
zeros can't keep track of quantum
information fineman's 1981 speech was
actually the first work to specifically
discuss the construction of a machine
that would operate on quantum mechanical
principles using Hardware that employs
quantum physics itself to keep track of
it accurately he came up with just one
rule for something that would match his
vision that the size of the computer
would only need to be proportional to
the size of the physical system it was
simulating that is he said if you want
to explain this much physics I can do it
exactly and I need a certain sized
computer if doubling the volume of space
and time means I'll need an
exponentially larger computer I consider
that against the rules that's followed
by a comment saying I make up the rules
I'm allowed to do that most conventional
computers fail this rule when trying to
simulate nature because every time you
add just one more particle to keep track
of you're adding a near Infinity of new
places it could be and it becomes
exponentially harder to compute Fineman
says that to get around this we should
let the computer itself be built of
quantum mechanical Elements which obey
quantum mechanical laws so what are
these quantum mechanical elements well
I'm going to use the black opal platform
to demonstrate this next bit as it says
here the fundamental unit of quantum
information is the cubit in normal
Computing we have bits of information
that can be either a zero or a one but
for a cubit the information is much more
crowded it can be pictured as a sphere
and we need two numbers to specify how
much the Cubit is one and how much it is
zero these cubits especially when you
have multiple of them contain a lot more
information than conventional bits can
hold and so given the fact that we hope
to have quantum computers with millions
of cubits one day this will take us to a
realm far beyond what conventional
computers are able to do here's a cubit
that we can play around with the top of
it is marked as the zero State and the
bottom being marked as the one state if
the blue line is the state of our Cubit
then we can move it all around the
sphere swapping from zero to one or
somewhere in between there's an infinite
range of possible options where the
state of the Cubit can live on the
surface of the sphere and that
corresponds to the increased information
storage in quantum computers there's
more than one way to make a cubit and
really it comes down to needing two
energy levels that are separated by some
known Gap that's because with quantum
physics it's a lot about energy at its
fundamental scale and with energy you
can have something called a ground state
which is the lowest energy of a system
and then an excited state where it's you
know elevated one above that and an
example given here in this energy level
diagram shows I think a particle in a
ground state in blue that when it's hit
with light it might absorb some energy
and thus go to an excited state where it
has more energy than it did in the
ground state and it could give off or
emit that energy to go back down and
that is fundamentally the the kind of
dynamic needed to make a cubit one
practical way that people can engineer
that kind of system is with trapped ions
the ion in this case is an atom that has
lost an electron and so has gained a
positive charge and because of that it
can be trapped using electric forces so
they have this trapped ion and because
it has one Lonesome electron remaining
in its veence shell they can actually
manipulate that electron with laser
so hitting it with a laser might be able
to put it up into its excited state um
and then coming down again it can go
back to its ground state probably
emitting light in the process and that's
how they're able to control this Cubit
using lasers and electric forces and
voltages though they might be small now
in terms of the number of cubits rather
than the overall size quantum computers
are real and available for anyone to use
many labs and institutions are in to
make them better and today you can write
programs that run on quantum computers
quantum computers aren't just good for
simulating nature they are also powerful
at solving other problems that also get
exponentially more complex such as
optimization and cryptography quantum
computers have the potential to improve
many different fields and industries
drastically but if the problem doesn't
have exponential complexity then you
wouldn't need a quantum computer to
solve it you'd be better off sticking to
regular computers feeman finished his
speech by saying he's not happy with
attempts to model physics just using
classical Theory because nature isn't
classical damn it and if you want to
make a simulation of nature you'd better
make it quantum mechanical and by golly
it's a wonderful problem because it
doesn't look so easy so why don't we see
quantum computers everywhere already
well it comes back to what Fineman said
Quantum Computing is an easy and many
smart people are trying to work out its
challenges one of them is noise quantum
computers like all electronic devices
can experience interference imagine a
phone call getting disrupted similarly
quantum computers can get affected by
various sources such as electromagnetic
waves from Wi-Fi or fluctuations in
Earth's magnetic field this interference
causes the data in cubits to degrade
traditional Compu computers are
relatively resilient their building
blocks transistors can perform billions
of operations every second for countless
years without any interference induced
faults on the other hand quantum
computers are delicate a cubit can
become unpredictable from interference
in mere milliseconds Quantum information
is actually very fragile even a
measurement can destroy it that's why we
don't take a measurement of the quantum
State until until probably the last step
in our process because we don't want to
destroy that state before we finished
performing the computation and as it
says here more is worse when it comes to
cubits because they each bring their own
noise and there's additional noise when
the cubits are connected together the
more cubits you have the more difficult
it is to protect that fragile Quantum
information it says here that someone
moving a chair in the lab housing the
quantum computer is enough to change
cubit so there's an almost endless list
of possible errors the quantum computers
that we have today are small and noisy
so we can't use them for the same things
that we would want to use a perfect
quantum computer for and instead we are
currently looking for things that are
okay to use a noisy quantum computer for
there's actually a name for the era of
quantum Computing that we're currently
in which is nisk or noisy intermediate
scale Quantum and this plot here shows
the situation the green line is digital
technology or normal computers and it
shows that in the past in what they've
called the digital era these normal
computers were better at doing things
they had more computational power than
the early Quantum technology but the
power of these Technologies is getting
closer until this point here where it's
going to cross over this is the point
when Quantum technology is going to be
able to do more than what digital
technology ol can do that's going to be
really soon for us and going to be
really exciting because after that point
the quantum technology will continue
climbing and the Gap will get wider
between what quantum computers are able
to achieve and what digital technology
could that would be the quantum error it
says here that when a device is built
with a few hundred cubits not even all
the digital computers in the world
working together would be able to store
its state in memory and so with just a
few hundred cubits we'll be able to do
things that no digital computer would
ever be able to do the only thing really
standing in our way and preventing us
from Building B right now is noise one
way to reduce noise is with error
correction error correction algorithms
have been made and used for conventional
computer chips like the ones that are up
in space they needed to be more
resilient to radiation that could cause
errors
for the quantum version of error
correction the key idea is to encode a
single Cubit of information across
multiple physical cubits creating a form
of redundancy by spreading the
information out and entangling the
cubits any errors that occur can be
detected and corrected without directly
measuring the cubit's value thus
preserving the quantum information
inevitably some cubits will go bad but
if at least half is still good then you
should be able to correct them the
problem with this approach is that it
requires more cubits which bring their
own noise and then the number of cubits
required to perform basic error
correction balloons out to dwarf the
original cubits by as much as a th000
to1 it's theoretically a viable approach
but right now there's a Global Research
effort just trying to get to the break
even point where it's actually
beneficial to use quantum era correction
given how many resources it takes the
other more obvious way to reduce noise
is in the hardware itself in cooling the
quantum computer to below the
temperature of outer space and shielding
it from the surrounding environment
scientists are also exploring the very
best and least noisy materials that they
can use to make the Cubit but there's
one other approach to reducing noise
that's kind of in between these two it
can be thought of as Quantum firmware
and protects the cubit against noise
without needing extra cubits one method
is dynamic stabilization which applies a
sequence of precisely timed pulses to
the cubits these pulses effectively
refocus the cubits and counteract the
effects of unwanted external noise this
concept is somewhat similar to
techniques used in medical MRI scans
where timed pulses help to produce
clearer images the goal of dynamic
stabilization is to average out or
nullify the effects of environmental
disturbances over time and as a result
the cubits are able to maintain their
Quantum state for longer allowing for
more accurate Quantum computations Some
Noise sources might not be mitigated by
this technique alone so Dynamic
stabilization is often used in
combination with other error correction
and noise reduction strategies Q control
who is the sponsor of today's video
specialize in making this kind of
quantum firmware their software helps to
make today's quantum computers actually
useful they also have an educational
platform called Black Opal which teaches
skills that would be useful in the
quantum Computing era I have enjoyed
working through their course on Quantum
fundamentals black opal allows you to
build interactive circuits and this is
my favorite part seeing the relationship
between parts of a circuit and what's
going on with the St state of the Cubit
X is a Quantum gate that is analogous to
the not gate in classical Computing so
it will change a Z to A 1 or a 1 to a
zero and it does that by rotating
180° around the x axis the Y and Zed do
the same but by rotating around their
axes and combining them you can trace a
path around the Cubit H is the adomar
gate which puts the Cubit into a super
position but between Zer and 1 so
halfway between each state there's a
link in the description where you can
sign up for free to see for yourself if
you would enjoy diving deeper into some
of these Quantum ideas and you can use
the offer code ties to get 20% off their
Pro Plan this could be the start of your
journey into a career in Quantum
technology after all there are many
Quantum Computing companies out there
now and they all need to hire people of
all types not just physic but software
engineers and marketers product managers
and designers and understanding the
fundamentals of quantum Computing can
really help to get into those jobs in
Quantum Computing companies too thank
you to Q control for sponsoring this
video and thank you for watching also
thank you to my patreon supporters for
making these videos possible and a
special shout out to today's patreon
cats of the day Duchess and
Rudy